let's attempt to take the antiderivative
or the indefinite integral of X to the
third time's the square root of 9 minus
x squared DX
and you might attempt to do something
like u substitution but you'll find that
you're not getting very far and we have
a big clue here we have something of the
form so 9 minus x squared u can be
viewed that can be viewed as the same
thing as 3 squared minus x squared and
anytime you have the form a squared
minus x squared it might be useful to
make the substitution that X is equal to
a sine of theta now why would that be
well then a squared minus x squared
would become would become a squared
minus a squared sine squared theta which
is the same thing as a squared times 1
minus sine squared theta I think you see
where this is going this is a squared
times cosine squared of theta which
might be a useful simplification so
let's do it over here in this case our a
is 3 so let's make the substitution that
X is going to be equal to a sine theta
or 3 times sine of theta and then when
we and then we're going to also have to
figure out what DX is equal to so if you
take the derivative and we will get DX
we could have DX D theta is equal to 3
cosine theta or we could write that DX
if we wanted wanted to write it in
differential form we could write that DX
is equal to 3 times cosine theta D theta
this is just the derivative of this with
respect to theta and we're ready to
substitute back our original expression
now becomes it now becomes I'll write in
that original green it now becomes 3
sine theta to the third power which is
the same thing as 27 sine actually let
me color code it just so you know what
parts I'm doing so this part right over
here X to the third is now going to
become 27 sine to the third power of
theta or sine theta to the third power
and then all of this business 9 minus X
this is going to be the square root
of nine minus x squared so minus nine
sine squared theta and then DX let me do
this in a new color
DX right over here is going to be equal
to that's not a new color DX DX is going
to be equal to all of this business so
times three times three cosine theta D
theta
now we let's see if we can simplify this
business a little bit the square root
let me do this over the side the square
root this thing right over here can be
written as 9 times 1 minus sine squared
theta which is equal to the square root
of 9 times cosine squared theta and we
can assume we can assume that cosine
squared or the cosine theta is positive
as we did in the last video and so this
is going to be equal to this is going to
be equal to 3 cosine theta3 3 cosine
theta in orange so this right over here
is 3 cosine theta and so what does this
simplify to
we have a 27 times 3 is 81 times 3 times
3 is going to be 243 so this is going to
be 243 I'll put it out front times the
integral of so you're going to sine
cubed theta sine cubed theta and then
you're going to have cosine theta times
cosine theta we could say cosine squared
theta cosine squared theta that's this
term right over here and this term right
over there and of course D D theta I
think I've taken care of everything so
it might not look like I've simplified
it a lot because hey look this still
doesn't seem like a trivially easy
problem to solve but we are getting
closer now this turns into just a
classic u substitution problem and it's
not obvious just yet it's actually a
little bit of a lair of a technique to
figure out first how do you do u sub
tuition right over here and the key when
you when you have powers of trig
functions especially when you have one
of them is an odd power what you want to
do is separate one of those odd powers
out so you can kind of construct a
u-substitution problem so let's do that
so this is going to be equal to 243
times the integral of sine cubed theta I
can rewrite as sine of theta actually
let me write it this way as sine squared
theta sine squared theta cosine squared
theta cosine squared theta and then I
still have one sine theta-1
a sine theta right over here D theta and
D theta and what I'm trying to do is
turn this expression to something where
I can do use substitution and as you
could imagine maybe where the D U has to
deal with sine theta D theta and it
would if I can get my U being equal to
cosine theta then my D U is going to be
negative sine theta D theta so let me
see if I can do that so if I if I say
that sine squared theta is the same
thing as 1 minus cosine squared theta
then this whole thing becomes 243 times
the integral of 1 minus cosine squared
theta times cosine squared theta times
cosine squared theta times sine theta D
theta times sine theta D theta and I
want to be very clear what I did over
here so we use some trig substitution to
get to this point right over here and at
this point I took one of the sine Thetas
out I separated it right over here and
then I converted this to an expression
in terms of cosine theta now the whole
reason why I did this is right over here
I have a function of cosine theta and
then I have something that's pretty
close to the derivative of cosine theta
right over here so this is now ripe for
you substitution so let's do u
substitution if I have some function of
something and then I have its derivative
maybe you should be equal to that
something so let me set u as being equal
to cosine of theta cosine of theta then
D U is going to be equal to negative
sine of theta D theta well I have a sine
theta D theta I can multiply that
is a negative as long as I put a
negative out here I'm multiplying by a
negative twice I'm not changing the
value so notice now this right over here
is d u and this right over here is a
function of U so let's write it that way
all of this business is going to be
equal to negative 243 times the integral
of 1 1 minus u squared u squared times u
squared times u squared and then this
right over here is just our D U so this
is just D U now this is pretty
straightforward we can just multiply we
can just multiply our u out and this
will become this is going to become
negative 243 so this is all equal
negative 240 3 times the indefinite
integral of U squared u squared minus U
to the fourth u squared minus U to the
fourth I'm just distributing the U
squared D u D u now this is pretty
straightforward to take the
antiderivative of this is negative 243
times the antiderivative of U squared is
U to the third or 3 antiderivative of U
to the fourth is U to the fifth over 5
and of course we're going to have a plus
C out here and just so that we can get
rid of this negative we can swap this we
can distribute the negative sign so this
one becomes negative that one becomes
positive and we get and we get all of
this business as being equal to as being
equal to 243 times U to the fifth over
five minus U to the third over 3 plus C
and you might say wow finally we are
done but we aren't done we have
everything in terms of U while our
original integral was in terms of X so
in the next video we're going to unwind
all the substitution we're going to try
to take this expression right over here
and write it in terms of X so we're
going to go from u to theta 2x because
we've done two rounds of substitutions
you